today's video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace their templates an
all-in-one platform makes creating an
online identity super duper easy there's
nothing to install patch or upgrade ever
and Squarespace provides award-winning
24/7 customer service 3 a.m.
help me place it's never been easier to
sell products or services online
keep dreaming but make it a reality with
Squarespace
so check out Squarespace calm for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
squarespace.com slash just kidding news
for 10% off your first web site or
domain all right now onto our video is
bad news oh I love salty what's a salty
AF so maybe by China bog China bonk what
is that most bones I made in China
Houston Rockets fans
hit Ayesha Curry's new restaurant
location with one-star yelp reviews
before it even opened
that's oh well does is mad at the
cooking and stuff yeah that's just a
YouTube channel that nothing about my
meant to be like destiny is Asia curry
just so you know the channel right yeah
I love rainbows oh she got light eyes
like Steph Curry yeah yeah it looks like
Nikki's opposite shirt oh oh I do
cooking - you guys are started a YouTube
channel you like
last time it'd be more like brown sugar
and pepper
Oh brown sugar is better than slow
ground sugar yeah brown sugar another
brown sugar light in dark brown sugar oh
that's right my in dark sugars cane
sugar right it's not funny anymore
hey you took it too far what else we
have what else do we have molasses and
what come on now cinnamon turmeric and
cumin anti-inflammatories [ __ ] you lost
me there we go there's something better
I - I don't know I'm a [ __ ] up I would
have believed you
Himalayan salt oh my god good job Joe
that's it be the Himalayan salt she's
pink as [ __ ] that's true
she's not why she's peachy hella pink
but when she's called she's burrito
flour tortilla this whoa when I first
met Jeff he said to me he goes is this
kids like a tortilla pouch I bought yeah
yeah yeah that's okay holder and I
looked at it and I looked at her skin I
was like oh my god Mexican food Oh Mike
so she became what she ain't my
girlfriend South Texas yes Jess when
she's happy she's me out right now I'm
sorry she's cussing your ass out too
[ __ ] joke Houston rocket lost
two warriors back in the Western
Conference Finals yep that's why they're
saying why the hell would I Alicia
curry open a restaurant in Houston after
what her husband did to it good to us
it's so fans are so [ __ ] funny no I
love sports right but what the [ __ ] do
you mean us I know I hear we sound like
you're not doing [ __ ] yeah you are not
the basketball game yes maybe but
they're not playing you don't mean like
oh we lost no they lost but it's like a
country and that's their army but it's
too insane
and if it crosses over to food
you say we that's nuts so you say we
yeah like what's the call by critic
wrote [ __ ] Anderson Silva shin you
don't see me going around looking for
Chris Weidman you know me you [ __ ] well
he could kill me that's why but some
people take it seriously if you're on an
opposing team and like your team wins
and like everyone else in the bar is
that for the other team like people have
died like get gotten in Europe the
soccer teams are even crazy I got riots
and rumbles be righted when they won the
Super Bowl
oh yeah that's good is Philly all right
so you should curries restaurant is
called international smoke and she
opened one in the Bears okay it's a BB q
yeah and it's a really big hit up in the
Bay Area oh so she just wanted to start
opening up in different cities like big
Food City barbecue makes sense
so that's ballsy this is a Yelp page
it's like a lot of Warriors fans helping
her and then rock it 400 wearing the
wrong colors that being a sausage in a
in a rice she got back up to three stars
after all those ones so just because
that's just people putting a random
pictures up there cuz I was gonna say I
would eat that yeah
bland half-baked disrespectful
overexposed not worth your time is this
about the food the decor the owner yes
jazmyne and then they're from Los
Angeles yeah so there's not even in
Texas whoa food keep your burp bebé cute
in California
this is h-town they didn't even have
moist brisket waited 35 minutes for
water and it tasted like Seth Curry
tears will never be back can't support
this place Harden MVP who's seth Curry
yeah who's Seth does that is his brother
oh okay all right
or they can't spell all stars later and
you try bringing barbecue to the H do
you know we are the south it's not
international it's southern smoke smh
well what if they have like baking duck
then it is international barbecue
kind of bold though I definitely
wouldn't bring California barbecue to
Houston that's what I said it was ballsy
on her it's a ballsy [ __ ] cuz I
definitely wouldn't do that because like
barbecue is like quick to essentially
like something that sudden people
[ __ ] love about their [ __ ] in the
cases has its own style
where's she originally from nothing it
doesn't matter I don't even know
California has California barbecue
videos oh there is it sushi holy Santa
Barbara style and it's the kind where
the tri-tip if it gets try to pop a
collar though right go like this and use
you you are Canadian America you go up
and down with that little girl thing
that goes I mean I think that's bar but
barbacoa or something in Santa Barbara
they're all about tri-tip BBQ and
triceps that type of barbecue I don't
know I think it's kind of [ __ ] up like
she has nothing to do with it it's
definitely [ __ ] up but she kind of ran
that risk what is she doing perfectly
well what if that was the fight that
spent all her money like like baby
that's not a good idea to do it oh [ __ ]
because just people that love food
everyone loves food whether you they
hate your [ __ ] team or not
and he's like no babe you just don't
understand we can't do this and then he
tried to tell her no and she goes [ __ ]
you and then they flop and then she
opened up and then this is what happened
and he's like see babe I told you was
gonna happen
why why why can't it be the other way
around where she's like I don't want to
I want dude he's I can't do it do I do
it because it's her restaurant you can't
tell her what to do she's the boss
that's why you got me on your side I
like Texas barbecue it's so good man
every place that I've been to in
California it's been okay it's not the
same though except for our friend Stevie
hey shoes so that sauce is good but
they're Texas barbecue cuz they're from
Texas she didn't care there no comment I
haven't read anything from her side Dan
that is [ __ ] that's kind of messed up
though like she's pregnant
it's like she's guilty by association
well then on the flip side though she's
also getting it crazy good views because
her fan so you kind of have to take the
good with the bad right yeah it's just
still messed up though I just all
pressure I don't I don't like people
from a food perspective no just as human
beings your is very vindictive you know
you're cutting that within the whole
thing behind Yelp - it's like how are
people from Addis
I guess we could be billfold okay I'll
take it out yeah and that's like the
problem with the up to like I think like
Yelp is a good thing and also a bad
thing too because some people just write
[ __ ] just to write [ __ ] some people
write bad reviews because they had a bad
day you know I mean and that's why
people you see yelp review is just like
I woke up today and I wasn't in a good
mood it's like this isn't your diary
[ __ ] I saw like a sandwich or not
yes I'll someone give a restaurant one
star because the table next to them was
loud yeah that's that's nothing to do
with the food the service the decor
people don't realize how much it impacts
this is they don't care there's no
social responsibility I feel bad for
some of these businesses because
sometimes you ever hear about the Yelp
mafia though well that Yelp if they want
to come after your business they'll just
like make all of your alt send all these
like one star reviews and they'll like
completely destroy your business Yelp
itself
yeah like a rumor it's a rumor but like
there's a documentary on it like the
Yelp mafia I gotta watch that [ __ ]
because the money yeah exactly they want
you to pay a little Yelp sticker yeah
for advertising on yeah and what if they
do that to a real mafia Italian
restaurant and then bake it oh that's a
good movie that'll be dull yeah movies
like you want to one stop me huh before
I quit good name Albert yeah my round
was like would you trust a man like Jack
Ma Jack Ma we use Chinese right and it's
funny because Chinese people hate
Chinese people and he was all like would
you trust a man like Jack Ma and I'm
like well he's a he's a billionaire he's
like worked really hard to get to where
he is he goes he's ugly as hell I won't
trust anybody that yeah Jack Ma Alibaba
Jack Ma legit looks like William Hung
anymore from the sea we look it up he
was like a heel if I eighty likes
straight up I don't think he's from this
earth that's how dopey he has he looks
like he has that disease what does he
say lien disease No
they had that disease that kid that was
on that just looks like a regular asian
guy like a Chinese dude looks like a
Chinese guy that kid looks like he looks
like a regular you know what he looks
like everything is like straight it's
like that it's [ __ ] that is not what
normal Chinese people look like you know
what I figured it out good
I'm not saying normal abnormal I'm just
saying I see him on the street I'm not
I'm not looking at looking twice yeah
look if he's not hot but I've seen like
white women looking like that I feel
like yeah there's nothing special about
it nobody looks like to me he legit
looks like somebody made a racist
Chinese Lego yes oh you look weird I'm
just like yeah same it's just a person
yeah there's a Finnegan I just see
everyone as blobs anyway so probably
wait until he makes a joke and then his
dick is huge if he's funny he's hot as
[ __ ] he's pretty funny
he trolled everyone why don't everybody
told him but you know he's a billionaire
yeah so he's a big fan of kung fu
he funded his own pretty much Hong Kong
Chinese Expendables and I got all the
greats
Donny and Sammo hung Jackie Chan Jet Li
he put himself he put himself in there
as one of that's great and everyone was
super Donna Duke he's the [ __ ]
billionaire dude that's like youtubers
like whatever they want to do they're
just like yeah I'm I'm a dancer now oh
yeah finger now I got the I got Michael
Jackson's vocal coach yeah
youtubers are so I wanted to do that
it's so funny cause like I think
sometimes like fans boost up their
confidence so much yeah yeah I'm a
singer it's like no you're not a scene
no but I got
I got the best vocalist Taylor Swift
vocal coach yeah I think that doesn't
make you a singer like what can't you do
and I'm like that you can't do that too
many yes Mary
[Music]
[Music]